Pamela Fox: Just curious,
how many of you
were in the earlier talk?
The grab bag
kind of--sweet.
All right, cool,
you guys are like--
we just kind of have a club of
people that like maps and stuff.
All right, so now
we're gonna get into
a bit more
of an advanced topic,
and talking specifically about--
we're talking about
the 2D maps APIs here
and performance tips.
As we know,
performance is really important
to making
good websites.
And there's a couple of us
that are gonna be talking today,
so there's me, and most
of you guys know me now,
and we have Sasha
from Redfin,
and we have
Marcelo from Google,
from the Sydney office.
Do I need this part?
Right, right.
So, uh, so the reason
we're talking about this:
because one of the things
that's really important
to us at Google
is latency.
And I'm sure you heard spiels
from Larry and Sergei before,
but basically,
we're not gonna launch something
unless it's fast enough,
right?
If the web page is fast, then
the user is happier using it,
and they can get
what they want to faster.
And when you think about it
from a Google perspective,
that means more time
for them to click on ads.
So, uh,
more money, right?
So that's what, you know,
kinda what it boils down to,
but, basically,
latency is really important,
and we want to make sure
that you guys
can use our stuff,
and create fast experiences
for your users.
It's really when I--
like, I monitor Twitter
for Google maps API,
and whenever
I see somebody say,
"Oh, the Google maps API
is taking too long,"
then I get really sad
and cry.
So this is really just
a session
so that I don't cry as much.
Still a bit, though.
All right, so, um,
one of the initial things
that makes an API slow
is actually
loading the API
because JavaScript
loads into the browser.
And to talk about that
we have Marcelo.
Marcelo: Hi, guys,
my name is Marcelo.
I work on the Maps API team
back in Sydney,
and I'm here to talk about
latency issues
when loading
the JavaScript API.
So, as you know,
the browser has--
there are
a lot of resources
before I can actually display
interactable, uh, map
to the user.
Mainly image files
and JavaScript files.
These resources are loaded
in a very well-defined sequence.
And let's call, for now,
the sequence
the Loading Sequence.
So I think it's interesting
for us to take a closer look
at how time is spent
during this loading sequence.
that can have some insight about
where the latency hotspots are.
So the first thing
that comes down the pipe
is the bootstrap.
The bootstrap is
a small JavaScript file
that the browser
downloads
when it encounters
the maps API--
the script tag
at the top of the page.
The bootstrap comes down,
gets executed
at around 2.5 seconds,
and it will then download
main.js.
Main.js is the bulk
of the JavaScript API.
It get downloaded
and initialized
at around
3.1 seconds.
It's only after the page
has set a center on the map,
that the map will actually
start downloading tiles.
On a typical map,
we know that setCenter's called
at around 3.8 seconds,
and the tiles
will finish downloading
at around
4.6 seconds.
So, there you have it--
around five seconds
before the user can actually
start interacting with the map.
It's not too bad,
but it's not great.
But if you look on
the iPhone and Adroid platform,
the numbers look
pretty scary.
Main.js, for instance,
takes nine seconds
to download
on the iPhone.
That's in comparison
to 3.1 seconds
on the desktop platform.
And the tiles
would only be visible
after 18 seconds.
That's 13 seconds later than
you would on a desktop platform.
So we think
that's pretty unacceptable.
So there's
a couple reasons for that.
One of the reasons--
just too many files
for the browser
to download.
First, it comes the boostrap
and then main.js,
and they have to be,
because of their nature,
they have to be
downloaded in sequence.
We can not
paralyze those.
And only after the map
know where the center is,
they can start
downloading the tiles.
A typical map will require
from 9, 12,
all the way up to
25, 36 tiles,
depending on
the size of the map.
And, as you guys may know,
each file request
carries a lot of overhead,
especially over
a high-latency network,
like 3-D,
for instance.
So that's where
the 19 seconds is coming from.
So what we suggest
to get around this
is to use
the Static Map API.
So with the
Static Map API,
you can fetch
a static view of the map,
put that into--
into the maptive,
and you're able to show,
you know,
a useful map to your user
much earlier.
Of course,
it won't be interactable,
but the user
will get to see something
while he's waiting
for the
[indistinct] API to be
downloaded in the background.
If you do that,
you will be replacing,
in this specific example,
a 200KB download,
split over 10, 20 small files,
with a single download
of around 80KB in size.
So it's, you know--
you're much more likely
to give a map
to a user earlier.
I have
a little demo here
that implements this.
Let me just
show you guys.
Let me just...
May I?
I clear your cache.
Pamela: Uh, yeah.
Marcelo: Okay.
So let's just see here
the on-demand demo.
Pamela: Thank you to Barry
in the audience
for this demo.
Marcelo: Uh, okay.
Pamela: What are you
looking for?
Marcelo: Uh, sorry, oh.
Pamela: Oh, yeah.
Marcelo: Okay, there you go.
So you can see there,
it's downloading
the page
and just a static map,
and show that
shortly to the user,
and wait until
the user clicks--
the user click
on the map.
That's when--
the JavaScript API
is actually downloaded.
And this other demo here
does sort of
the same,
but it doesn't wait
for the user
to track
to the map.
So it doesn't
transition really quickly.
Of course,
if your user
is in a slow connection,
he--there will be
a delay
where he wouldn't be able
to interact with the map.
but that's better than
get a blank div.
So...
the other big reason
why it can be so slow
to load a map
on a mobile device
is just the sheer size
of the API.
If you look at this,
this is the list of classes
that the public interface
implements.
And that all adds up to
about 220KB of JavaScript.
The problem
with this
is that
we just recently found out
that the iPhone takes
around 20 milliseconds
to parse each KB
of JavaScript.
So if you multiply that,
what you get is 4.4 seconds.
That's the amount of time
that the browser will wait
for the Jesup engine to digest
all this JavaScript code.
And during this time,
the browser
is completely
unresponsive.
So again, it's a really
unacceptable user experience
in our opinion.
So to try to alleviate
this problem,
what we are doing
is offloading some of the code
that currently sits
in main.js
into js modules.
These modules
can be downloaded dynamically
after the tiles
have arrived,
so they don't
hog the CPU
during the
start-up sequence.
So far, we've been able
to modularize around 20%
of main.js,
but unfortunately,
there's a major obstacle
to this work.
which is the fact that the API
was designed a few years ago
around a synchronous
programming model
that doesn't play really well
with dynamic modules.
And the fact that we cannot,
for obvious reasons,
change the public API,
makes this a major, uh,
show-stopper for us,
as far as
motorization goes.
So after a lot
of discussion
back in Sydney,
the team decided
to bite the bullet
and start working on
the next generation
of the API,
which we call Maps API v3.
The Maps API v3
is being released today.
There's a blog post up.
The [indistinct]
is also up.
You guys can check it out--
see what you think
about the API,
give us feedback,
maybe try the demos,
even try to come up
your own mashups.
And I'll just finish
my presentation here
with, you know,
a few bullet points
of why we think that
v3 is so special.
The first thing is, uh,
v3 is built from the ground up
with latency in mind.
So we are going for
a very aggressive
JavaScript
modularization,
and that fact that we don't have
a well-established API,
a legacy API, if you like,
to hold us back
is a real blessing.
We also baked
some latency-specific features
into the API.
So, for instance,
the Static Map optimization
I just told
you guys about
is actually built
into the API,
so it's really easy
for developers
to deploy that
into their websites.
And, last but not least,
we really, really committed to
the iPhone
and Android platforms,
and we hope
we can provide
the best
user experience possible.
And Susannah,
who is with us today,
will be giving
a presentation tomorrow,
where she'll go
into much more detail
about v3
and how to use it.
So I really recommend
you guys attend.
Pamela: All right,
thank you, Marcelo.
[applause]
Pamela: So now with that
nifty new android you got,
you can make maps
that work really well on it.
You see.
So, I know we didn't
give you an android,
but we gave you a tool
to harness on the android,
which is
just as good, really.
So that
is our new API,
and that's going to solve
some of the latency issues
with loading in
JavaScript in lots of resources.
But there are still
other performance issues,
both for that API and
for the current API generally.
So one of these
is the issue
of trying to display
many markers on the map.
Now, this is a very common
question we get in the group,
is, "Hey, I tried to put ten
thousand markers on the map,
and then
my browser got really slow."
Well...
what can I tell you?
You tried to put
10,000 markers on the map.
So the thing is,
that remember that
the map's
API JavaScript
was originally created from
the Google Maps JavaScript,
which meant that everything--
all the classes we had
were classes
we originally designed
for the use case
we had in mind.
And the use case
on Google Maps
is you do a search,
and you get back
ten labeled markers,
and that's it.
Google Maps
almost never--well,
sometimes they do now,
but generally never shows
more than ten markers at a time.
So to design
the GMarker class,
with this in mind.
They wanted
a lot of features.
They wanted printability;
they wanted dragability.
They wanted foregrounds,
shadows.
They wanted hotspots
that would work
in every single browser,
including IE6.
All this, which means
that GMarker
is a really
full-featured class,
which means that
it actually contains
a lot of DOM nodes
in order to create it,
and make it work
correctly.
So that means, if you try
and put 10,000 markers on a map,
what you're actually
putting on a map
is something like
50,000 DOM nodes.
And the thing is,
if you try and put 50,000
DOM nodes in the browser,
the browser gets
really, really sad.
So we don't want to make
it sad so it cries.
So what you can do
is that,
in the API we have
a GOverlay interface,
and you can extend
this overface
to create
your own custom overlay.
So I'll just show you
an example of one that I made,
so you--all you have to do
is make a marker
that just doesn't have
as many features
as our marker has,
and is optimized for
what you want
your markers
to accomplish, right?
If you want your markers
to have thousands of them,
and, uh, be clickable,
you can do that with not much
lines of code at all.
So we can see
a demonstration here.
I'll do GMarker.
It's gonna be
a bit slow.
And we're adding
a thousand--
oh, that's gonna be
really bad.
You can see
the shadows turned up first,
and then we have
the markers.
So that kind of
took a while,
and then--well, panning
isn't really, like, that fun.
So now, I'll do...
a thousand Marker Light.
So you see
that was a lot faster,
and the panning
is smoother too.
And even then, this isn't
an extreme optimization.
All I've done here
is create an overlay
that has one div
with an image DIV inside,
so I've reduced
from 5 DOM nodes to 2 DOM nodes.
So this is a performance
enhancement already,
but you can go
even more extreme than that,
and I'm gonna have
Sasha from Redfin
talk about
his extreme solution.
Sasha: I don't know
how extreme it is,
but, uh, so as Pamela said,
my name is Sasha.
I work for Redfin.
We're an online
web real-estate company.
And, from the beginning,
we took the map
as the center
of our user interface.
It's--you can do, sort of,
polygon-based search,
you can search
for neighborhoods,
and we show a lot of houses
on the map by default.
We show up to 500
at a time,
and it's been a problem for us
for a long time.
So, we actually--
we actually took Marker Light,
and we've added
a bunch of stuff to it.
And I'm just gonna show you
how it works on our site,
and then take you through
a very simplified
version of the code
just to--so you get an idea
of what the code looks like.
All right.
It's in Firefox, right?
So here we are
at Redfin--
Let's give ourselves
a little bit more space.
We've got some houses
on the map;
we're looking at
Potrero Hill.
Let's say, though--
we, you know,
we're interested in, what,
in the bargains,
so let's look at, uh,
San Francisco,
let's say, under 550K.
That's affordable,
right?
All right,
so it just added
477 things
to the map right there.
And you see it happened
pretty darn fast.
This is actually
waiting for the network.
And...that's adding.
And so we're adding--
so you saw the demo that
Pamela just did
of adding a thousand
normal GMarkers.
Obviously,
it happened a lot faster here.
So how do we do that?
So we did, basically,
what Pamela just described:
subclass GOverlay.
We called it, actually--
We called it SuperMarker,
which, 'cause,
I don't know,
'cause we wanted to do
one better than
Marker Light, I guess.
[laughs]
So what you do is
you subclass GOverlay,
and this is just
really simple beginning code
to say, "Okay, we've got a layer
and a DOM node."
We're holding
onto a DOM node.
The basic way
this strategy works
is, as far as
Google Maps is concerned,
SuperMarker is
just one marker.
The thing--the GOverlay subclass
is just one marker on the map,
but underneath it we're gonna
draw stuff inside SuperMarker.
So we're gonna--we're basically
gonna keep track of
all of the things
we want to put on the map--
all the houses
we want to put on the map
and tell SuperMarker about them
sort of secretly.
So you have to implement
a method called initialize,
which gives you the map,
uh, the G Map
you're a part of.
And all it's doing
right here
is just creating
a DIV element
and adding it to
a particular pane in the map.
So this is the DIV element,
the DIV node--
it's gonna--the DOM node
it's gonna hold on to
to do
its own drawing.
Now you--you implement
a draw method.
And there are
a couple interesting things
to look at
in this one, in this thing.
And most of the interesting
performance things here
don't really have to do
much with the map.
A lot of you
probably know some of this,
but, as Pamela said,
adding 5,000 DOM nodes
makes things very slow.
But it's also so--you wanna
reduce the number of DOM nodes,
and we're only doing
one DOM node per marker, here.
But other things
that help are
that you don't do--
use the DOM APIs,
that you make
a big string,
and slam it all in
within your HTML--
makes it much faster
to add things.
You'll also notice that,
instead of doing, you know,
plus equals on the string,
it creates an array and
joins the array at the bottom--
also much faster.
And the third thing
to notice
is that
it actually is creating--
we're--in this--
in our version
we only create one DOM node
per marker,
and then we use
what's called CSS Sprites
in order to put
the image on it.
So rather than
doing a DIV
with an image
underneath it,
we use--we have one
gigantic, uh, image
that has a bunch
of different kinds of icons
because we have about,
I don't know, maybe
a hundred different icons
depending on what kind
of house it is,
what type of house,
whether it's
a favorite of yours, et cetera.
We put them all together
into one giant image
that's just one download
to the browser,
and then we use CSS--
the CSS background image--
to select out
little pieces of that image.
So it's just
a DIV with a background.
The downside of this is...
won't print.
As Pamela said,
markers are very full-featured.
They have
all these things.
They have shadows,
they have printability.
You're not
gonna get printing,
but it's gonna be
a lot faster.
So that's
the drawing right there.
And then finally,
once you've written
this GOverlay,
all you need to do is just,
basically, add it to the map,
and underneath
the covers, you tell it,
"Hey, here are the ten things
you need to draw."
And it makes
the DOM nodes for you.
And that's it.
[claps]
Pamela: So that was all
using the JavaScript API,
but, actually,
the Flash API,
though it does tend to be
a lot faster at stuff,
can still run into the issue
of having
too many things in the DOM.
So people
in the Flash API community
have implemented
really similar solutions
to SuperMarker.
I think they call it
Super Overlay.
And where did you
drag it to?
Too many tabs.
You guys
are cheating.
You can see
too much.
All right, I'll just
open it.
So here's an example:
this is a map of victims
of some dude named Madoff.
You guys probably
know more than me.
This is
a Flash map,
and you can see
it's got thousands
of markers on here,
and as I
mouse over the markers,
I still have
interactivity,
and they even
raise to the front here.
So that's the thing.
When you implement
your own overlay,
you can
implement stuff, like,
you know,
changing the Z index.
It's really
entirely up to you
what you want
to implement there.
All right.
Still this hasn't really
solved our problem,
if we want to put
ten thousand markers.
This will work pretty good
for five hundred markers,
for a thousand
markers.
But ten thousand markers--
that's just too much.
Even just
ten thousand DOM nodes...
that's still too many
to put on the map.
So there's a couple
different solutions here.
One of them
is clustering,
which is becoming
more common now.
Here's a classic example
of clustering,
which is
AuthorMapper.
You can see it here,
and they have stuff, like,
individual markers
to signify, okay,
there's only one author, here,
and then multiple markers
to say,
all right, this is
a cluster.
They also use
the coloring
to indicate
the size of the cluster.
So you see, okay, red means that
there are more articles there,
and yellow means less.
And these are standard features
of clustering sites.
Here's another example,
which is [indistinct].
And, you see,
they also use numbers
on the cluster markers,
and when you mouse over,
you get a little thing
that says, "Oh, this is how many
things are here."
And now you can zoom in,
and then the clusters
would expand out
to either more clusters, or
maybe some individual markers.
And you can see
some of them here.
So this one is actually--
the way they implement this
is that--I think it's every
night or every week or so--
they crunch through the data
on their database.
They run it through a
K-means Clustering Algorithm,
and then they save out
the cluster information
to their database.
So it is
a fair amount of effort
for them to actually implement
this clustering algorithm.
So what--I'm really happy
that now, actually--
a few month ago
we announced MarkerCluster,
an addition in
the Open Source library,
and what MarkerCluster is,
is that it's actually
a JavaScript-only
cluster
that will do
all the clustering for you.
And all you have to do
is pass in...
pass in
the data that you want.
And it's
a very naive cluster,
okay, it just does--
it, basically, uh,
breaks it up into
a pixel grid,
and you can kind of specify
the size that you want.
And then it will figure out
the best clusters.
But they thing is, like,
K--
you don't have to write
a K-means Clustering Algorithm.
It'll do it
purely in JavaScript,
so you don't
have to store
a database of
your marker clusters.
And it's pretty fast
as well.
There's an example
that does
a performance test
as well.
So if you're looking
for a very fast
clustering solution,
I highly recommend
checking out MarkerCluster.
Since it is open source,
you could tweak it yourself
to, uh, if you need
to change the algorithm a bit.
So that's kind of
standard clustering.
You could also do
regional clustering.
So if it makes sense
to cluster your data
by some political region
like city, state, country,
continent, etcetera,
then you can divide all your
data into those clusters,
and make cluster markers
for each of those.
And you see,
in this example,
when I mouse over
one of the cluster markers,
I actually see the outlined
polygon for that region.
So that's
a nice hint to the user,
like, hey, these are actual
regional clusters.
And they understand, like,
oh, okay,
this represents
California.
Because that's the thing
with clusters--
is that you want
to be clear
about what
it's actually representing.
You can see
that here.
And, actually,
travellr is a site
that just launched recently,
which is kind of like
Yahoo Answers for the map,
and probably has smarter users
than Yahoo Answers does.
And you can see,
it's nice.
They start off
with continents.
And we can mouse over and see
what they represent.
They haven't done
border polygons yet,
but I've asked them to.
[laughs]
Nicely.
What I like--
this is a pretty good
user experience here,
because I know exactly what
these clusters represent,
and I can zoom in
to see more information.
And they implement this
on the server
using--I think it's
a B plus tree
or something
like that.
So those are different types
of clustering you can do,
and it's kind of
up to you, like,
how extreme
you want to take it,
and how much
you want to customize it.
There's an article
here
that compares the various
clustering arguns available.
That's a link to some sample
K-means clustering code
if you want to
write it yourself on a server.
And Maptimize
is actually a, um,
basically, you give them
their data,
uh, you give them
your data,
and they'll go
run it through
their own clustering algorithm
on their server,
and then they'll just
give you some JavaScript,
for you to include
on your site,
and get the clusters
to show up.
So they're kind of
a hosted clustering solution.
And you have to pay.
A bit.
Not too much.
So there's clustering,
and clustering
is what you use
when you want
to make sure
that the user can eventually
actually click on the marker.
Because with clustering, you can
always zoom in far enough,
and actually have
clickable markers.
But that's not
always necessary.
Sometimes when you have
ten thousand markers,
you don't really care
about people clicking.
You just care about them
visualizing the information
that you have.
So there's a couple ways of
doing View-only visualizations.
So this is, um,
FundRace from Huffington Post.
And this is
really nice here.
What they've done
is that
they geocoded
the campaign contributions
from everyone
in America,
and then plotted them
on the map.
And then
what they did was--
they actually
created tiles,
and then they put them
underneath
our hybrid
upper layer.
And so these tiles--
it's basically like
dot density mapping.
They've just done
a pixel
for every contribution
that they have.
And it's pretty cool because
you can go and zoom in,
and then see,
in your area,
exactly how red it is,
and how blue it is,
and whether you should be
hating on your neighbors,
and stuff like that.
And it's good because
it doesn't--
you know, you can click on it,
and you can zoom in,
and you can see-you can get
the general idea
of how red or blue
an area is,
but as a user
I don't really expect
to be able
to click on a pixel
and find out exactly who that
pixel represents...right?
I can look and see some samples
in the sidebar here,
and see who--what kind of people
these people are.
But they don't have to worry
about people mining down
to that--
individual pieces of data.
So this is
something you could think about,
and this does involve
actually rendering out
tiles on your server,
so they have some
image manipulation,
where they're just
writing pixels into the tiles,
and then
putting them out.
Something similar
you can do
is a HeatMap,
and there actually is a
HeatMap public API you can use.
And there's also
some open source projects--
there's on
called G Heat,
to render out
these tiles.
Because a HeatMap,
once again--
you're probably gonna
have to render tiles.
If you use Flash,
you could actually do HeatMaps
purely in Flash.
You don't need to render
your own tiles,
so we do have a demo of that
in the gallery.
This one is
a tile HeatMap,
and it's nice--this is
a search for pizza.
So this is just
to give me a general idea.
If I went to Boston,
and I desperately needed pizza,
what general area
would I go to?
Right?
But, um, the thing
to be careful about HeatMaps
is that the user understands
what they're looking at here,
and that it's
actually useful data.
You know, it could just be that
every heat map
looks like this
for Boston
because the most amount of
restaurants for Boston is there
in the city, right?
So you may look at
comparing what data you have
to population data
to make it
more clear for the user.
all right, and
here's a solution
which is kind of a mix
of all the other ones,
which is
really, really cool
and something that
Google Maps is doing now.
So we were talking
about earlier:
it used to be,
you do a local search,
you get back
those ten markers,
and they represent
the top ten results.
But sometimes you want
more than that, right?
You're like, "Okay,
I searched for pizza."
"I know that there's more than
ten pizza places in New York."
Right?
So we wanted to have a way
of indicating that to the user,
and giving them
a better way of visualizing
what their search result
really looked like.
So we introduced
these things
that we affectionately
call pimples,
and they look like
little pimples or measles
on top of
the map.
And I'll, actually--
I'll just show you
in the browser.
Here we go.
So here I've done
a search for Chinese food.
And it's cool because
when you look at it,
you can actually--
you can see--
you can tell
where Chinatown is.
Chinatown is where
the G and the I are.
And that's where the most number
of local search results are.
And with these pimples,
if I say--
well, so I
actually live--
I live right about here.
So I can go and click
on one of these
and actually find out
that result.
Right?
But the thing is
that these aren't
actually
little markers.
What these are
is just a tile
that's been rendered
and made clickable.
So the way
we make it clickable
is that, at the same time as
rendering these tiles,
we passed down
some JSON.
And you can look and see
the JSON...
here.
So here's some
example JSON--
that doesn't really
increase it.
But basically,
the JSON just contains
information about
the clickable pixel bounds,
so we say,
all right,
we're passing down
these tiles,
and this area's clickable,
this area's clickable,
this area's clickable.
So when you do the mouse over
event, you can go and query,
"Okay, which pixel bounds
am I in right now?"
"Should I change my cursor
into a pointer?"
And when somebody
actually clicks,
we can go and say,
"All right, what have I actually
clicked on?"
"Should--what information should
I open up there, right?"
And you could do
an AJAX call
to go fetch
that information
by some ID that
you stored in that JSON.
So this
is really nice
because no matter how many
search results we have,
we're downloading
the same amount of data
but for the user,
it's a clickable experience.
So this is how
you can kind of mix
being able to visualize
lots of information
with having
scalable performance.
And we use this
for other things, too.
We use this for
our photos layer.
And videos,
Wikipedia,
web cams.
So this is
technically--
if these were done
as markers,
the map would just
absolutely die,
but these are just combination
of clickable tile layers on top.
And we have
a demo of this
from on of the developers
who's in the audience.
So this is a slightly different
way of doing it.
And you can see here,
as I mouse over--
we don't do
click behavior here--
but, um--
oh, we do?
What happens
when I click?
[laughs]
Okay, well, I don't have it
in Firebug right now.
But you can see that
the mouse cursor is changing
to indicate that these
are in fact clickable,
and that you get
a very satisfying experience
when you click.
And the way--
[laughs]
The way he's doing this
is really, really cool
because, uh...
So in the other example
on Google Maps,
we passed on the tiles
and then we passed
on a separate
JSON.
What he does is
he renders the tiles,
and the he attaches cookies
to the tiles.
And when he gets
each tile,
he just parses out
the cookies,
and the cookies
contain the information
about the clickable
pixel bounds.
So in one single
request,
he has
all the information needed
to make clickable tiles.
So, John, you should
raise your hands
because a lot of people
have questions.
Yeah--so I know some of you
asked me earlier about this,
so you should talk to John
after,
if you're curious
for more information
about how
he did this.
Okay, so that's a problem
with having lots of markers.
So now let's move on
to polys.
So the first problem
we have
is the same problem
we had at GMarker.
It has a lot
of features.
GPolygon, GPolyline--
they have lots of features;
they can be, you know,
edited.
They're clickable.
They can, um--
they can be
geodesic.
We do
bounds clipping.
Lots of optimizations that
we've done on GPolygon,
and all really catered toward
their use on Google Maps, right?
So it may be that
your use of polygons
is different from
our use,
and you may have to come up with
a different solution.
So the first answer,
and this is--
it's a very similar story
to markers--
is just to do
a lightweight polygon class.
So the same way
we can extend GOverlay,
and make
a lightweight marker,
we can extend GOverlay
and make a lightweight polygon.
And so this demo
actually comes from
another developer,
Mike Geary.
All right, so he just--
he's in the back of the room.
And, this is called
Polygonzo,
which is
an awesome name.
And you can see what
we're using here
is, uh, this is using
the Canvas Tag.
And if you guys saw
the keynote earlier,
I think they talked
about Canvas.
Canvas is
awesome.
It's just a way of drawing
graphics in the browser.
It's part of
HTML 5.
It is in
most browsers,
except IE.
But he manages--
this thing hacks
on top of VML
to make really, really fast
VML.
So, 'cause IE
does have VML as a solution,
and he kinda just figured out
how to make VML
be as fast
as possible.
So it does work
in IE as well.
So here we're actually
loading in 34,000 points
and about 3,400
shapes,
which is
pretty amazing.
And then--
wait, wait for it.
Ready?
Oh, yeah,
that's good.
We'll just take it in for a bit,
guys, just take it in.
And I'm sure
you guys are thinking, like,
"Oh, I needed animated polys
that were rainbow-colored."
"Yes!"
But this kinda--
it's kind of silly,
but it exemplifies
how--how fast this is.
And this was developed
while they were working
on the election maps,
because they needed
to be able to visualize
all of the voting districts
on top of maps
and do it
as fast as possible.
And they didn't want
to use tiles
so this is a solution--
they don't need tiles.
And you can see,
when we mouse over,
we can actually see, um,
all the information about the
county we're mouse overing.
So that's the thing--
JavaScript is actually pretty
fast at doing calculations
about what bounds
it's inside of.
So really fast
at pixel bounds
and even for doing
polygonal bounds.
This thing is
figuring out on the spot
what we're
mousing over.
So that kind of information--
or that kind of processing--
can be done
entirely in the client now.
You know, granted,
maybe if you do
20,000 places instead of 4,000,
maybe you'll get a bit slower.
but a lot of people
tend to think
that this is stuff that you
need, like,
a spatial server
to do
and you have to go
send it off
to the
Oracle Spatial Database--
that's what I had to do
in university.
But it's not really
that necessary anymore.
You just do a nice little
JavaScript function,
and for the most part
it will work.
But even so,
even having
this lightweight poly,
you still might
have the problem
where your polygons
just are too thick,
and have
too many points,
and this is actually
a pretty common problem.
Because a lot of times,
when we get data,
we get it from sources
that don't think about the fact
that eventually it might be
rendered on a map, right?
So GIS people,
they go out,
and they go and, like,
record this pixel, and then
record this pixel.
So they come back with
massive amounts of points
that represent
these regions.
So you can see that Alaska
is actually, like,
ten times the amount of points
that America is
because Alaska just has
this crazy coastline
that goes like that.
So what you want to do
is simplify your data
before you render
on to the maps.
So you should be simplifying,
probably, on the server.
And you can use
a couple different programs.
This is a nice online one
that will actually show you
interactively, like,
how it's shaping, and show you
a couple different algorithms
for simplifying
your data.
And there there's some,
you know, Python scripts
and what not that
will do this for you as well.
So just make sure
you're not
trying to render
too many points on a map
because often times,
your users don't need
all that point
information.
And, uh, you should certainly
simplify it first.
All right.
Now there's situations
where your users
do want the information
about all those points,
but they don't want
that information
until they've zoomed in,
you know, pretty far, right?
So you can see,
in this example,
this line is at, you know,
some higher zoom level
and as we zoom in,
we see more and more points.
And you can do this
really easily in the API
using something called
encoded polylines.
And so,
encoded polylines--
you basically
take your information, like,
"Okay, this is my polyline,
and here's all the points."
"And the points are gonna
display at this zoom level."
And so we'll figure out--
you give us
the encoded information,
and we'll figure out, okay,
we're gonna show this points,
'cause we're at
this zoom level,
and we're gonna show this points
'cause we're at this zoom level.
So that's
a nice optimization
because it means that, if
the user is at this zoom level,
you can potentially show
a lot more polylines
because it's gonna add up
to the same amount of points
that you'll have just for that
one at the higher zoom level.
So we have documentation about
how to write encoded polys,
and there's lots of scripts
that can do it for you,
and then,
in your database,
it could be a more succinct way
of storing your encoded--
your polyline information
as well,
because you would simply
store it as
a giant string
of information.
All right, but
saying all that,
you're still
gonna have the issue
where you're gonna go
pimp it out,
and you're gonna use
Polygonzo,
encoded polylines,
and then you're gonna test it
in Firefox and Chrome,
and be like, "Oh, my God,
that was the best site ever."
And then you're gonna test it
in IE, and you're gonna cry.
So the problem is that when
it comes to vector graphics,
the browsers still
haven't agreed.
So we have this situation where
in the API,
we actually have
four different techniques
for rendering polys.
We have VML
for IE,
and we have
SVG and Canvas.
I don't remember which one
we do where
because we change it
every week,
and then failing all that we
actually have a graphic server
to render tiles
out for graphics,
but we don't usually
have to use that anymore.
So, it's
a sad situation,
and anyone doing
anything graphical on the web
knows that
it's a sad situation,
and we're also desperately
bribing IE
and trying
to get them drunk,
and saying,
"Hey, Canvas, wahoo!"
But it hasn't
happened yet.
So this is the situation
with vector graphics on the web.
So there's a couple different
solutions for this.
One of them is to give up
on the web and use Flash,
which I'm a huge fan of;
it's much easier.
[laughs]
So let me show
Flash examples.
The great thing
about Flash is that,
number one, it works
pretty much the same everywhere,
except maybe
on mobile phones.
And the other thing
is that, um,
it was kind of designed
for this kind of thing:
doing graphics
and vector graphics.
So it works
really well.
So here's a demo
using Flash,
and this is
visualizing
how San Francisco voted
on Proposition 8,
which is kind of
an interesting vote to see.
And we can go and change this
by one or two choices.
There's a bubble, um,
oh, percent.
So it's really nice;
it's really fast.
And you can put a fair amount
of polys on the map,
and there's actually a blog post
which I linked to here
that shows
all the countries in the world
and does a comparison using
the JavaScript API,
and using
the Flash API.
And that's interesting
because you can go
and bring it up
in the different browsers,
and you'll see--in Chrome,
actually, it's pretty similar
because Canvas and Flash
have pretty good performance.
But once you open it up in
a slower browser like IE 6,
then it all goes to hell.
And Flash doesn't have
that issue.
But another solution
you can use for JavaScript,
if you're still holding on that
the web is gonna get better,
and it should,
is to use tile layers.
And this is basically
what we do on maps, right?
So thing about
our road map tiles
is that they have
a huge amount of vector data,
but all that vector
is baked into the tiles,
and that's how we get
such good performance
because, no matter where
you go in the world,
you're always
just loading in
the seven tiles that represent
that part of the world.
So you can create
these tiles layers yourself.
And you can render whatever
vector data you have
into those tiles
and basically bake
your polygons in there
and then overlay it
on top of our tiles.
So here's another demo
from John.
And he's just
generating these tiles
from his
Postgres database,
and, uh,
you can see as we zoom in--
it's just loading more.
Actually, I'll do this
in Firebug
so you can actually
see the tiles.
So you hid my stuff
in view, yes.
So we'll do images,
outline images, all images.
So here you can see
I've outlined the images.
So you can tell that
they're all tiles.
And it's a combination of
his custom tiles
with our
hybrid upper layer.
And you can see,
as you zoom in,
one of these tiles becomes
four more tiles.
So this is just
an image pyramid.
So if you're creating
these tiles yourself,
you just have to have a script
that will write out these images
and then create
an image pyramid.
So basically
the world is divided
into an X-Y-Z grid, um,
three-dimensional,
and everywhere in the world
you have a tile
representing
that grid.
Now you probably don't
want to actually pre-render
all the tiles,
especially if you're covering,
like, a large area,
like all of America
in every zoom level.
So there
you probably want to have
on-demand
tile rendering,
so that you only create
the tiles
for the requested
viewport, right?
'Cause it actually is
quite a bit of space
on your hard drive
to store tiles for zoom levels
1-21 in the world.
It's like trillions of
terabytes and stuff.
That's approximately...
number.
[laughs]
So yeah--so actually that's
everything I had to say
about performance tips.
So there's a lot here,
and a lot of options for you,
using API v3,
combining it with some of
the techniques we talked about.
Using API v2 and using
some of the techniques.
Using the Flash API.
Lots of things to to that can
make for a better experience,
and of course
we'll keep working
on trying to bake these things
into the API.
So with v3
we baked in
that Static Map
optimization
because we knew
a lot of people wanted it
but didn't want to go through
the effort to implement it.
So where it makes sense,
we're gonna keep trying to do
the work for you,
so that you
don't have to do
as much of this optimization
yourself.
So I just
want to talk about
the qualified developer program,
again,
for any of you who wasn't
in the earlier session.
So this program is
to help us find
all the qualified
Maps API developers out there
and badge you,
and be able to point
people to you.
So in this program
you can sign up,
and you can register yourself
as a vendor,
and then
take a test,
and provide
some references,
and indicate if you've done
community forum support.
And then we'll see
if you qualify,
and we can give you
a badge,
and then anyone
who's looking for
maps API developers
can go find you
in our Vendors Marketplace
and then
contact you for work.
So if you are
a freelance developer,
please give this a try.
It's fun,
taking tests.
I love it.
You love it, too.
So give it a go and please
send us feedback about it.
This is the first--
we're rolling this out
for the Maps API
before any of our other
Google APIs
because the Maps API
has traditionally had
a pretty strong
freelance community,
and we never really had
a good way of recognizing them,
and giving them their--
a spotlight and way
for people to find them.
So if it goes well
for Maps APIs,
then it goes over the world,
and you can get qualified
for everything.
I personally plan
on getting qualified tonight.
It should be easy since
I wrote half the test.
audience: [laughs]
I felt bad when I failed
my own questions, though.
All right, so now
we take questions.
If you have questions,
you come up to the mic.
Thanks, guys.
audience: [claps]
[clicks tongue]
No questions?
If you--can you
come up to the mic and do it?
And I should plug--
there's Ignite.
If you guys
have never seen Ignite,
we're doing Ignite
at IO.
And Ignite is five minutes,
20 slides, 15 seconds,
auto-advance.
It's a very
interesting format.
And I'm doing
one of the talks
so I'm freaking out
a little bit.
But that's at 4:00 in, I think,
the room across the way.
So I recommend that
four your 4:00 slot,
if you haven't done
anything for that yet.
Yup.
man: Hi, do you know
of any implementations
where you have, like,
a group of markers on a map,
and it auto-determines what
the appropriate zoom level is
so that they're not
all bunched up together.
Pamela: So that's, basically--
you can stay up.
That would basically be
marker cluster,
like, it figures out--
Oh, actually, no, no.
So we have something called
MarkerManager,
and what MarkerManager
does is, it says--
you give it batches
and you say,
"Okay, I want these markers
at this zoom level,
and these markers
at this zoom level."
But the thing is, there, you
have to pre-decide the batches,
but somebody
for the Flash API
wrote something on top of
the Marker Manager,
which will automatically
figure out,
like, nice zoom levels
for that.
So I think he called it
multi-level MarkerManager,
but I can ping you
the link after.
man: Thanks.
Pamela: Yeah, so
that doesn't do clustering.
It just does random,
like--
oh, there's a lot here
so we're not gonna--
we're not gonna show
all of those at this zoom level.
Right.
man: I have close to
4,000 markers,
and a layer
of polygon.
I want
both of them clickable.
Pamela: Okay.
man: So far, I'm using
the XML parsing
so that I can hide it, you know,
or show it whenever I want.
Pamela: Yep.
man: Now,
what's happening here
is that
every time I click on the link,
the parsing is going on
in the background,
and I don't want that.
How do we stop it?
It's taking forever, so.
Pamela: Um, what is it
parsing when you click?
man: It's parsing
the XML file.
It just has the
lat-long information,
and just a description,
that's all.
Pamela: Okay, well, the first
thing I would recommend that
is instead of using XML,
I would use JSON,
since it's natively
supported in JavaScript.
So you'll get
a slightly faster
parsing performance,
there.
man: I see.
Pamela: And then--JSON, you can
make pretty compact.
You can really make your keys
be really short
and stuff like that.
So I recommend JSON just as
the data transfer format.
man: Okay.
Pamela: And as for--
I don't know what your
exact setup looks like,
but I would look at
how much data you're downloading
and how much
you're parsing,
and whether maybe you can
segment it differently.
And maybe--I don't know
what you're doing exactly,
but you could do
more efficient stuff
if you only load in the data
for approximately that bounds
or something like that.
man: Yeah, unfortunately,
we don't have that option.
We want to see all the
3,000 markers at the same time.
And then as we move in,
you know,
the other 2,000
kick in.
Okay, so I'll try
the JSON for that.
Pamela: Yeah, try JSON
with some of the things
we showed here
as well.
man: Okay, and
the second question is
do you have thematic mapping
support for AP--uh, for maps?
I know they recently came out
with one for Google Earth,
which was like, something,
last week or--
Pamela: Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, this guy,
this developer, Bjrn Sandvik,
from the
thematic mapping blog.
He made it--he used
the visualization API
with the Google Earth API
to make it really easy
to do thematic mapping.
Just--I think he does it
country-base.
So you can make a spreadsheet
that has a bunch of countries,
and codes,
and then it will go on plot them
on Google Earth,
doing different
visualization techniques.
So that's just something
a developer wrote.
We in--
I'd say, in the APIs,
we really haven't
baked in
any sort of
thematic mapping.
But lots of people have done it
on top of it.
So I would love for us
to bake it more in,
to make it a bit easier
to do thematic mapping,
'cause it is
hard right now.
But there's a fair amount
of data out there
and, of,
geometry data,
'cause the first thing you need
is geometry data.
And in the group
we have...
long--that's not
what I'm searching for.
So we have--
well, we have a bit
easier to use--not that one.
This one:
GIS Data.
This is a long list
of data sets
that we've kind of
collected,
so UK boundaries,
world data sets.
This one's really cool:
dyne geometry.
They'll actually give you--
they give you
the encoded polylines
and a JSON for all these regions
in the world.
And they also offer
a web service as well
to give back
the geometry.
So there--
it's certainly--
It does require
a bit of effort
to, you know,
find that data
and then decide how you want
to render it on the map.
But there's nothing
stopping you from doing it.
man: Okay, okay, and the last
question would be
is there a JavaScript
support in KML right now?
My objective is to--
when I'm clicking on
a small href link,
it should pop up
a window,
rather than just popping up
a whole--
rather than redirecting it
to a completely new blank page
or some page.
I just want to limit that
to a pop-up window.
Pamela: Right, so,
as for KML support in the APIs,
in the JavaScript API v2,
we have this class
called GeoXml,
and that takes a KML file
and renders it on the map.
But we don't provide--
it doesn't provide
any more customization
on top of it.
It's just
putting on the map,
and then however we render it
is how we render it.
And you can't
control it.
So a lot of people
have written
open source extensions
for parsing KML,
so there's E GeoXml,
and there's GeoXml.
And these will read in the file
and display it,
and then you can
customize more
of how that KML
is displayed.
But the thing there
is that
it's rendering it using
native GMarker and GPolyline.
So you'll still
suffer from performance
if your KML file
is quite large.
So you could look
at combining
E GeoXml with, maybe,
Polygonzo or Marker Light
if you need to have
a lot of geometry in your file.
man: Okay, I see.
All right, thank you.
Pamela: Yup.
man: I got a question regarding
the Redfin solution.
So, yeah, you're not using
DOM nodes,
and you're kind of
breaking up the DOM string
and then you are using
innerHTML,
but ultimately
it's still DOM elements,
and then anytime that
you're gonna be panning the map,
it is still
gonna be slow.
Are you doing anything
to work around that,
or is your solution basically
just to solve the drawing
and not worry about
the panning and stuff like that.
But it is part of
the mapping faction.
Sasha: So, if you don't mind.
Pamela: Yeah.
Sasha: Yeah, so, clearly
panning is also a problem.
I mean, most browsers--
500 divs is not that bad...
is not particularly bad.
And we spend a lot of time
worrying about the redraw.
The first draw is
gonna be the worst for us,
but we do a lot of stuff of,
like,
keeping an array of pointers
to all those DOM nodes.
based on IDs.
And, you know,
there's lots of
interesting things
you can do where you say,
okay, well, those ten
went off-map,
and I want--put ten
onto the map.
Okay, instead of taking out
those ten DOM nodes
and putting ten DOM nodes
back in,
or redrawing it all,
you can say, okay, well just
change the CSS style,
so I get a different
CSS background image,
and give them
a different ID,
or swap out their ID.
And now all of a sudden,
you know,
I didn't actually
have to do--
I didn't have to add
or subtract from the DOM,
which is
super-expensive.
You can also, like,
let's say
you know, half of the markers
went off the map.
Sometimes it's better
just to go through
and display
NONE nodes,
rather than
ripping them out of the DOM.
And then, you know,
we put in heuristics for, okay,
well, but if you know, sometimes
we put in heuristics--
we've tweaked this
a million times.
But, heuristics for things,
like,
okay, well, if I'm taking out
90% of the things on the map,
I should probably just take
the whole div
that contains
all of them out,
and just re-draw.
And so those are
a couple strategies we've used,
and actually,
to be honest,
I don't remember which ones
we're using right now
because we've cycled through,
I think, all of those.
And I think some of those
we're still using,
but it's a matter of
think of those, test them,
think of those, test them.
Does that help?
man: Yeah, and, just a kind of
general question.
Have you guys run into this
IE, of course, issue
where there's an HTML DOM size
limit of 175,000 pixels?
Sasha: I have not.
Pamela: No.
Sasha: I have never
run into that.
man: You guys are really lucky
if you haven't.
All right, thanks.
Sasha: Sweet!
Pamela: We have
other IE issues.
man: My question just
kinda has to do with G Unload.
v2 kind of introduced--helped
with all the circular references
and all that, but I see
a kind of absence in v3,
so, improvement?
Pamela: So, yeah,
that's an improvement.
'Cause we realized we could just
do G Unload ourselves.
'Cause we had you put G Unload
on the body on Unload.
But it's like, well,
why are we making them do that?
We can do that
ourselves.
So we do all of that
clean-up ourselves.
man: Cool.
Pamela: Yeah.
We actually had it, like,
a month ago,
and then we were, like,
this is silly.
We don't want to make
developers do it.
[laughs]
So you notice in the v3, like,
we've gone through and, like,
everything that makes it
into v3 API
we've kind of
analyzed it to death,
and fought,
and decided which things
really belong in this API,
and which things
we can do for you and stuff.
man: Sorry, I came in late.
About GMAP-3.
Are all the features
of GMAP-2
gonna be supported
in GMAP-3?
You just change
the architecture
to optimize
the performance, right?
Pamela: Yeah, so--
I should--we didn't really
mention that it's--
did you say it's
MVC architecture?
Marcelo: I didn't.
Pamela: Okay, so,
we're doing an MVC architecture,
which makes it easier for us
to bring new things in
because it makes it really,
really trivial to modularize.
And there will be more
information about that
in Susannah's talk
tomorrow.
But, basically, we're going
to look at v2 and v3
and look at the usage for
the features in v2,
and figure out which things
should be baked into v2
and also figure out which things
we can simply open source,
and put it into
its own library.
So we're gonna have
a bit more
of an official story
on extensions,
and maybe have slightly more
official extensions as well.
So stuff that we didn't
maybe think is necessary
to put into
that main core,
but we wanna make it really easy
for people
to integrate
with their maps.
So eventually, everything
should be supported
in some way,
as long as it was
something
that people actually used
in v2.
We actually did have
one class in v2
that we discovered
this year
had never been used.
man: Which one?
Pamela: It was...
gXML...transform...
GXslt?
man: Oh, yeah,
that's transform.
Pamela: Yeah,
it had a bug in it,
so it wasn't usable.
So that kind of class--
For two years, no one
said anything, right?
That kind of class we would
probably not have it
in this thing,
right?
And the thing also
to think about
is the Maps API
came out
before there were many
JavaScript APIs on the web.
So there's a lot of stuff
we put in the Maps API,
like, how to create
dragable objects,
how to do
XML HP request,
that's really not necessary
to have in a Maps API.
We just did it because people
didn't have any other options.
Now, most people use, like
jQuery, Prototype, whatever.
So it's silly for us
to replicate
the kind of general
AJAX-y things
that those things do.
So you notice that we probably
wouldn't put classes like that
into a Maps API.
man: So there's not gonna be
a GMAP Light, right?
It's gonna be GMAP-3
for both mobile and desktop.
Pamela: It's quite light.
It is light, yes.
[laughs]
man: Looking forward
to it.
Pamela: Okay.
All right.
Cool, so you guys can come
to Ignite now...sweet.
All right.
Thank you, guys.
Sasha: Thank you.
Marcelo: Thank you.